from Lupita nyong goes bravura double
performance in us to John Travolta
overacting in the worst way in the
fanatic here's a look back at the
highest highs and lowest lows of 2019 in
movie acting in us Lupita Nyong'o makes
the most of a rare opportunity to put
two totally different performances in
the same film while playing Adelaide
yong-go is anxious and twitchy with her
emotions building throughout the film as
she tries to protect her family while
playing Adelaide's counterpart red
Nyong'o is full of grace and danger with
such an unsettling presence that geomos
wants a flinch when she appears on
screen together Nyong'o plays the full
spectrum of emotions between two
identical characters that never once
leaves the viewer confused about who's
who it's an absolutely unshakable pair
of performances that carry the film and
only become more impressive on a rewatch
Jessica Chastain seemed like a perfect
fit to play the otherworldly alien buck
as she tries to bring Jean Grey over to
the dark side in Dark Phoenix
unfortunately while the third act climax
and script can be blamed on behind the
scenes drama that doesn't excuse how
boring her performance in the film is as
buck Chastain should be strange and
seductive and alluring contrast to the
men in jeans life that are trying to
control her instead Chastain just seems
sport delivering dialog as if she's
reading the script for the first time
what remains of my people search the
stars for that power to control it but
it destroyed everything that ever came
into contact with until you in mid Samar
Florence Pugh plays Danny as reserved
introverted and shell-shocked following
her family sudden death in the opening
scene of the film those feelings only
intensify when she gets a last-minute
guilt invite to her boyfriend's vacation
to a pagan festival that involves
psychedelic drugs and ritualistic
killing a lesser talent might have
played Danny's grief and probable PTSD
like a boiling kettle that slowly
explodes instead Pugh shows a more
naturalistic depiction of grief she's
looking for comfort from her no-good
boyfriend and trying to stay on top of
her emotions
while taking shrooms when her grief
finally explodes out of her in a ritual
of shared pain and screaming it takes
your breath away if John Travolta's
starring role in 2018 s mega flop Gotti
wasn't bad enough he delivered another
stinker in 2019 s the fanatic the film
follows an autistic man named moose who
becomes obsessed with a horror film
actor that obsession soon curdles into
an obsessive hate which leads to moose
stalking and threatening his favorite
star even if he could get past the
offensive stereotypes that Travolta uses
a short hand to communicate that moose
isn't neurotypical the actor just can't
handle playing a character that needs to
be both sympathetic and sociopathic at
different points in the film maybe
Travolta just needs one good film to get
back on top but the fanatic definitely
isn't it like Blade Runner another
science fiction film with a powerfully
ambiguous lead performance and a
burdensome voiceover attached to the
theatrical version ad astra feels like a
film destined to become a cult classic
in the decades to come while the film
has a dense script in some impressive
visual set-pieces
the core of ad astra depends on Brad
Pitt giving one of the most nuanced
performances of his career as Roy
McBride Pitt is the Sun and search of
his father not just in a metaphorical
way either
he's literally tasked by space comm to
head out to Neptune to search for his
dad in order to stop a series of power
surges that threatens the entire solar
system Pitt shines in the role
delivering every ounce of nuance and
backstory with only a few clenches of
the jaw or a faraway look M night
Shyamalan early superhero film
unbreakable ends on an ambiguous note
that seemed like it would never be
resolved that is until Bruce Willis's
David Dunn made a cameo at the end of
2017 s split revealing that the two
films took place in the same universe
that sets up 2019 s glass a film that
seemed to promise the long-awaited
sequel to unbreakable the good news for
fans is that
came out the bad news is that the film
itself is largely terrible squandering
the promise of unbreakable final moments
glass has plenty wrong with it but
Willis's poor performance would rank
high on the list an unbreakable willis
played gun with a quiet melancholy in a
reserved almost deadpan performance it's
a fine line to tread as an actor and in
glass willis misses the mark entirely
what was once an internal carefully
calibrated sadness has become a boredom
so obvious that willis was barely
mentioned in the reviews of the film
despite playing one of the most
prominent roles over the course of five
seasons aaron paul's eternally hard luck
addict jesse pinkman was basically the
moral center of Breaking Bad even in a
show beloved for incredible performances
Paul's acting throughout was a standout
that's partly why it was so mystifying
that he didn't become a major star after
the show's end
besides leading roles in 2014's Need for
Speed and the prestige television show
the path falls largely stuck to cameos
small roles or voice acting work El
Camino the film's sequel epilogue to
Breaking Bad shows exactly what
Hollywood's been missing and reminding
everyone how beautifully Paul can
inhabit a role his performance against
acting heavyweights like Jonathan banks
Bryan Cranston and Robert Forester make
it clear that Paul is one of the best
actors around have you been watching the
news
I have very much so so you hear what
they've been saying about me even the
best actors can have misfires and
Matthew McConaughey is no exception case
in point the bizarre misfire serenity
which ranks near the bottom of the
actor's career output McConaughey is no
stranger to turning stereotypical
characters into fully fleshed out people
but that same instinct seems to have
worked against serenity considering the
laughably silly plot twists it might
have been better for McConaughey to play
the role with this tongue slightly in
cheek rather than commit on the level of
his time on true detective check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]